if you play The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt on
the PC you can import your witcher 2
save files so that the third game
reflects the major decisions from the
second game but maybe you're not playing
on PC or maybe you lost your save files
forgot what happened or never play at
any Witcher game before so there's good
news
The Witcher 3 allows you to select those
decisions as if you played The Witcher 2
the bad news is if you didn't play the
witcher 2 you may not understand the
sequence that presents these choices in
this Witcher 3 sequence the nilfgaardian
emperor has invited you to his palace
but before you meet him one of his
commanders subjects you to a shave
during which he asks you some probing
questions if you haven't played the
witcher 2 you aren't likely to know the
background to these questions but fear
not I'm here to provide some context so
you don't feel completely lost when
you're confronted with this only
slightly lost choice one asks did you
kill aryan lavallette or allow him to
die aryan lavallette is or was depending
on how you do it
the son of the mistress of king foltest
of tameria in the witcher two's prologue
you confront him and he's commanding the
guards that provide his castles defenses
you can kill him and his guards if you
want to or allow him to live in the
witcher 2 if you kill him that opens up
interactions with his mother later in
the witcher 2
if you force him to surrender you
encounter him later and might even aid
in his escape from the castle choice
number two did you leave flotsam with
vernon roche or with your vez
so vernon roche is the military leader
and loyal servant to full test who
interrogated garel to the beginning of
the witcher 2 however he came to believe
that Geralt did not assassinate full
test and helped him in his escape your
vez is an elf and the commander of a
score tell unit square tell our non
human freedom fighters driven by their
hatred of humans yet they are known to
ally with human leaders should such an
alliance prove worthwhile at the end of
act 1
in The Witcher 2 you have to decide
whose side you're basically on this is
the witcher two's biggest decision if
you side with roche you go down what's
called roches path going with your vez
goes down your vets path in either case
you confront a series of choices that
you do not confront should you go down
the other's path furthermore the next
choice you make in this conversation on
The Witcher 3 depends on what choice you
choose here so if you chose your vus
path your third choice in The Witcher 3
in this conversation is this did you
save Tris at the LOC moines summit or
did you lift the spell that held Saskia
so if you didn't know Triss Merigold is
gerelds primary romantic interest in The
Witcher games and a pretty great
sorceress Saskia is a beloved warrior
who led a revolt when King Hensel tried
to invade her land at this stage of The
Witcher 2 Tris is imprisoned in a war
camp and saskia who's actually a
shape-shifting dragon is under control
of a powerful sorceress named philippa
eilhart if you chose Tris not only did
you get to have some fun in the camp but
you also got to see Tris accuse Sheila
de Tan servile another powerful mage of
being the puppet master behind full
tests death if you choose to release
Saskia from her curse she regains her
free will but there are damaging
repercussions for mages who now become
the victims of a witch hunt now if you
chose Roach's path in the question
number 2 your third choice is as follows
did you save Tristram her nilfgaardian
prison or did you save Anais lavallette
now
Anais lavallette is Aryans half-sister
and she is the daughter of king foltest
that means that nie is the true heir two
full tests thrown she's captured and
held by hensel's forces and should you
choose to rescue her you must again make
a choice handing her either / - the
kingdom of redania or - tameria if you
rescue Tris however things play out more
or less like they do on your vus path in
this case Tris gets to confront
to tan serval about her role in the
assassination your fourth choice is this
did you save Sheila de Tan serval from
her defective mega scope or did you let
her perish so a mega scope is a magical
device that's good for teleporting and
having conversations at a distance
unfortunately for Sheila leatherhead
sabotaged her mega scope Sheila tries to
escape while you watch however she ends
up in danger and begs for you to help if
you save her she disappears but only
after giving you a hint is where you can
find long-lost love yennefer if you let
her die well she's dead the last choice
you end up making is essentially the
last one you make in the witcher 2 at
all and that is did you kill Leto or
allow him to walk free so letõs a
Witcher and the man who actually
committed the crime Geralt is confused
of you meet him quite a few times over
the course of the witcher 2 but your
final act is to choose whether he should
live or whether he should die it may be
your last decision in the witcher 2 but
its consequences are simple the game
then ends either way so all of these
decisions end up playing a part in your
playthrough of The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
I'm not going to get into what those
consequences are because there are just
so many of them but I wanted to give you
some background either if you forgot
what happened in The Witcher 2 or you
simply were playing on a new platform or
just never played the games before I
hope you have a lot of fun exploring
this really incredible game
you